[Music]  behold the mighty mangrove renowned for  its toughness and ability to foster  sensitive marine life they play an  important role in tropical ecosystems  all around the world  and especially here in sri lanka  despite their strength the mangroves are  being destroyed to make room for  commercial farming operations and  development deals  but all hope is not lost thanks to sri  lanka's mangrove master  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  currently  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  douglas has worked formally doing  conservation work since 1992 and  recently became the director of a museum  dedicated to mangrove conservation  foreign  foreign  in addition to stopping destruction part  of his conservation work involves  planting mangrove saplings to replace  the trees that have already been lost  [Music]  is  [Music]  my  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you